Oh call the police and you demo is out
today this just came out it's so fresh
that Gattaca the cop got a called ah
alright so Resident Evil 7 teaser came
out I don't know but I think they're
trying to pull a PT here if you're not
familiar PT was a horror game that came
out last year it's officially the most
downloaded demo of all time not sure if
that's true but I think that's what that
what's that Matthew McConaughey is
confirming those numbers right now those
numbers are confirmed
so obviously how is Resident Evil 7
gonna promote themselves they're gonna
try and do the same thing they're gonna
try and drop a demo let's check it out
is it as good as PT highly doubt it
Resident Evil is really a franchise that
has gone downhill since number 4-5 was
[ __ ] 6 was garbage 7 will they bring it
back I don't know let's find out yeah
they're definitely piecing us right now
p-ting rest right now what the [ __ ] am i
although uh Resident Evil extension ASA
is already called there pretty
interesting I think I think I think it's
it's gonna be oh my god what is
happening I literally have the same
camera this is [ __ ] freakiest [ __ ]
dude you gotta see this I literally have
the same [ __ ] camera setup man
shotgun mic and everything oh my god
what the [ __ ] hey buddy I did that's an
expensive camera
[ __ ] hell do you know how much I paid
for that what were you doing man
yeah yeah
that is a [ __ ] fun-ass knife made so
that was the camera why is my mission
still like a camera an audio for that
matter in my robot just like dices
spielen be finder seek milk and
goddammit
Michael it's your German account again
oh I like the audio don't worry we'll
change it don't worry
oh hey I handed that alright not [ __ ]
we're not playing in touch alright
Japanese game have Swedish in luck team
like I now s-- is this on or off how
will I know I can't [ __ ] Fighter
press anyone I did it
I press T anybody whoa we're playing
right away Resident Evil seventies are
beginning our thank you for teasing us
probably spent a lot of money building
nice demo so hopefully it's a good one
get out of the house huh okay this looks
very interesting so far I have that same
couch what the [ __ ] is this Capcom you
trying to troll me I shall dash them
against the stones well that's what you
do right look they're playing MTV I
don't have a videotape I was a low key
burn everyone looks like we need a fuse
doesn't it Hughes is missing who has
fuses these big mighty aidez Hey
actually they're tiny I'm just kidding a
lover Martin please don't leave me
now where did we go got to find that
fuse doubt let's look around a bit find
some happy little clouds alright
apparently I'm a camera in my face Hey
look at that guy I have the same glasses
what the [ __ ] is happening here Capcom
you're trying to troll me I guess we'll
go out and look for the a fuse
ooh you press twice to open doors
dude this is a [ __ ] scare pretty high
season two men look at this [ __ ] hello
Annie
what did that other guy go alright
where's that [ __ ] fuse man trying to
check out the controls looks like we can
Crouch all right Mandy surprisingly like
amount of zombies a dummy finger awesome
thanks must have been jacksepticeye's
hey Oh Jack is just my go-to guy now I'm
so sorry
it's nothing personal just you're Irish
it's not your fault for being born Irish
yeah [ __ ] love you though alright let's
check the fridge maybe there's a fuse in
the fridge they go start on F so oh my
god that is I don't think anyone open
this fridge in a while it's they got
some good maggot cake though that's
pretty good yeah let's check the
microwave yeah I'm sure there oh god
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is that what
is that
close it thank you very much though that
looks not like I would like to have it
the [ __ ] is this
it plays beautiful there's a small key
hole just like mop
what was that it's anyone out here are
those mean bumping into the table where
am I the [ __ ] everything is closed god
damn this place suck
I'm glad you get the flashlight outlet
right away it gets so old like you have
to find the flashlight hello
oh god oh god oh what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I
did not expect to see that hey we got
bolt cutters every Bob Jesus what are
you come from
did I just squeal like a pig I literally
did I need a key to get out why don't I
use the bolt cutters I'm gonna see that
well this is going great so far guys uh
we found a pig so in half hope no we're
vegetarians I'm watching all right so
wait what okay you know what color color
me interesting so far this is pretty
cool the [ __ ] this is not a key to get
out VHS tape but you don't even know
what that is it's a nice cup right you
know what
I could paint this and make it nice
again just saying all right unnecessary
piece of information for everyone all
right yeah there was a TV in the bedroom
I know I know you don't have to tell god
there's upstairs as well Jesus Christ
let's start let's start with the TV
oh my [ __ ] dick
I don't think I should [ __ ] me in the
ass
hello why do I always go to like the
most sexual thing I can say when I get
scared it's [ __ ] with that pianos
gotta slam I'm going to slam it now
there you go big chest piano
with the VHS tape in
very interesting BHS 156
the limbic house June $1 a haunted house
haunted house rehearsal rehearsal what
what is this oh [ __ ] me Jesus Tom yawns
okay [ __ ] you doing here hey I only work
with professionals
speaking of which make sure the sound is
right this time I don't want a repeat of
Amarillo that was two [ __ ] years ago
I don't do ADR oh we're playing me we're
playing the VHS tape dude this is so
cool
not feeling it [ __ ] you I'm right here
don't be surprised if we have to make a
change
new plan we do a walk through the inside
first then we shoot the intro god this
guy is literally always do just try to
say the show's name this time okay ha ha
ha no problem tonight on sewer Gators
another worthless [ __ ] [ __ ] all in my
family I think I'm the camera guy dad
yeah I'm definitely the camera guy that
is brilliant
please be back to me arrested and evil
please be back I love you
are we rolling all right let's go yeah
we're rolling
ah got the camera here ready right here
Oh are we watching our own team yeah the
way that would make sense
Oh what we saw in the beginning it's
locked I've always wanted to do that
after you one day I'll do that hello so
why are we in hell this time
do you ever prep what's the prep shitty
house wookie sounds oh is it haunted
this is scary dude [ __ ] me
how was it anchor you know we can shut
not anchor what's that
ah nothing Pete is my hero a [ __ ] day
you talk to me this is the same house
what's the story Andre abandoned
farmhouse missing family foul play
suspected
usual how long do you say this place has
been abandoned three years
Clancy get a shot of this let's make a
great cut away so uh hillbilly Jonah's
family go missing not hillbillies the
baker's jack and Marguerite Baker and
they were quiet not backward a lot of
bad rumors about their son Lucas bad
seed apparently guys what was that sound
ah [ __ ] I know I should have wore my
good shoes oh [ __ ]
glad I had my shots why although just to
make a great backdrop uh hydrate what do
you think it does look good ha ha ha
Andre where the [ __ ] no Andre no are you
serious you see where Andre went oh my
god where is he I'm [ __ ] believable
it's the last time I work with that guy
I mean producers they come and go but a
good cameraman like you Clancy you stick
with me thanks thanks buddy
just from what you said before I really
feel honored all right Cameron McMahon
Killian see growl Kapow get all the
shots pal yeah dude this is gonna get
like 6 million YouTube mate did you hear
that this is some pretty pie [ __ ] man
should I should I go or you go you're
the hero you good you get your the star
yeah you go Andre
[ __ ] is he oh my god this is the room he
came from Audrey where are you man
well clearly not in here man oh [ __ ] me
man
what's with the fireplace why are you
looking there man
what the hell what you gotta be [ __ ]
kidding me
no all right new deal we we find Andre
and we go me [ __ ] this show honestly a
green but I don't think Andre is in
there though I don't know why you're
insinuating he's there you got a great
ass though let's keep this shot going
our three two cat crouched oh my lord we
are inside the walls of a Honda - this
is gonna be this is gonna get so many
[ __ ] hits on YouTube this is gonna go
viral viral horror videos [ __ ] yeah nice
hero shot of me coming down the ladder
oh you first I've been doing this this
is a really cool never try LCA this is
not what a slick today
what is it um like a bed and [ __ ] I'm
scared can I go up now you coming down
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god no Oh Andre oh boy
well we know how that happened then go a
cool story
what does it I shall - you against the
stone oh you against the stone he
changed
oh god please for the love of God well
that would it's pretty much all we got
out of that but now we know there's
something down here I suppose we can't
really do it twice can we we can do it
twice which opens up here but I don't
really see a point of going down here
twice you know what I mean there's the
keys okay thank you though God I am the
jet scared right now
this is [ __ ] freaky man I'm just
gonna keep oh my god
do you think he passed her
thank you that was just like a quick
spook I don't think he's actually there
okay we got the back door key now we
just got to get out get out I'm just
gonna run for it just gonna [ __ ] run
for it that seems like the right thing
to do right
Oh God oh go you son of a slow-ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] Oh God God he's a white
boom freedom
welcome to the family Oh oh [ __ ] it was
to dad
welcome to Dale what
hmm we gotta get out of here
don't cut my dick off we now know you
got the rope done you're gonna oh sorry
about that lady
we're the family's expecting you early
2017 what [ __ ] you [ __ ] you man you make
me wait that long how [ __ ] dare you
tease me like that why do they always do
that
tell me about the [ __ ] game a week
before and then I'll be like hey cool I
can play you can't make me wait that
long
what that [ __ ] you what a slap in the
face with a dick
yeah damn alright let's let's have a
little chat I'm impressed I think that
looks really cool it seems like a new
direction for Resident Evil which I
think they need to take so what do you
think let me know I'm very interested to
be fair though like I play demos before
that are really cool and then the full
game is just something completely
different but I liked how they kept it
small I like how they're trying to tell
a story and I think yeah it's very
interesting I was not paid to play this
demo or anything I'm giving you my
honest opinion and that's it let me know
what you think leave a like if you
enjoyed and as always subscribe to come
birthday I'll see you tomorrow Bros I
don't know why I did this in Truffaut so
forgot it's over you think this is a
game I tell you boy it's not
what the [ __ ] is that life stop it
you